bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
au coeur du parlement européen à
bruxelles pour ce nouveau numéro d'
europe hebdo
cette semaine notre reportage vous amène
en france dans la manche premier
département les pieds de france nous
sommes allés à la rencontre de
producteurs qui s'inquiètent de la
disparition des quotas laitiers en clair
le secteur va passer d'une économie
administrée à la loi du marché nous
entendrons les témoignages des
producteurs dans quelques instants mais
d'abord la question d'actualité comment
résoudre le casse-tête grecque
un député grec sera avec nous pour en
parler il est membre de syriza la
coalition qui gouverne en grèce d'abord
quelques éléments d'explication en
images
d'un côté un premier ministre grec qui
veut en finir avec la rigueur imposées à
son pays par bruxelles la banque
centrale européenne et le fmi
la fameuse troqua qui l'accusent de
paralyser le pays
de l'autre des européens d'accord pour
aider la grèce mais à une condition
l'aide promise plus de 7 milliards
d'euros sera débloquée seulement s'ils
atteignent s'engage à mettre en oeuvre
les réformes demandées par ses
créanciers
chacun campe sur ses positions les
négociations s'éternisent
mais le temps presse si rien n'est fait
la grèce pourrait se retrouver sans
argent à la fin du mois aux côtés du
président de la commission
alexis ce type race affiche sa confiance
je suis optimiste
nous avons la volonté politique de
trouver des solutions à nos problèmes
mais avec la volonté politique tout est
possible
j'exclus totalement la possibilité d'un
échec je n'en veux pas je veux que les
européens s'entendent ce n'est pas le
moment de se diviser
le chef de syriza devenu premier
ministre va-t-il accepter de renoncer à
son programme un salaire minimum
revalorisé
un treizième mois pour les retraités
pauvres l'électricité et le chauffage
pour les plus démunis
lui qui promettait de chasser la troïka
du pays devra sans doute revenir sur ses
promesses et l'europe sera t-elle
capable de concession en temps tels le
cri de détresse de la grèce asphyxiée
par la dette
un fardeau de 315 milliards d'euros
l'allemagne reste intransigeante avec le
soutien de la france qui presse
également son partenaire à respecter le
calendrier des réformes alors le
compromis sur le dossier grec est il
obligatoire
nous accueillons sur ce plateau pour
parler de ce dossier grec un député
d'origine grecque stelios couleurs glue
bonjour bonjour merci beaucoup d'avoir
accepté notre invitation vous êtes
membre de la coalition de la gauche
radicale syriza
vous avez pris vos fonctions ici de
député européen très récemment et vous
êtes écrivain journaliste vous avez
plusieurs casquettes et vous parlait
très bien français
alors dites nous comment vous voyez ces
négociations ce bras de fer qui semble
engagé entre alexis ce type race et et
les européens est ce que ça peut mal
finir pour vous écouter malheureusement
la troïka la sienne troïka a été
remplacée par une autre rica à qui
incombe aux et des trois choses menez
chantage et ultimatum il faut faire ça
dans bijoux sinon on va quitter
l'hérault on va avoir les carreaux se
touchant c'est la même chose finalement
c'est la même les mêmes absolument le
la même chose rien n'a vraiment changé
en ce qui concerne la dette id des
autres pays de l'europe vis-à-vis de
l'agresser et le respect est équipé du
désir des électeurs grecs parce que
c'est qu'ils essaient qui les problèmes
aidera c'est léger c'est la démocratie
est-ce qu'on va respecter un petit p les
électeurs d'un pays qui veut changer un
petit peu la politique de son pays ou
non passer sinon pourquoi faire des
élections où il faut aborder les
élections là on paie hier il coûte
région en coûte cher il faut organiser
les chandelles dr au régime
pourquoi perdre même temps c'est un
casse tête pour alexis tsipras ce parce
qu'il a promis des choses beaucoup de
choses à son peuple et vous dites il
faut respecter le choix du peuple grec
mais de l'autre les robes musique oui
mais si on fait pas les réformes tout de
suite dans ce cas pas d'argent à la fin
du mois comment se sortir de cette
situation
mais écoutez nous voulons faire des
réformes nous voulons faire dans le
compliqué les autres alliés en europe ou
repli que la banque centrale européenne
de la grece et de bonne volonté elle
fera les réformes inouïe mais écoutez il
ya par exemple le président de
l'eurogroupe a menacé la grèce et des
banques rendent il a comparé la guerre
la question chypriote à celle de la
grèce à 10 questions des deux choses
différentes
s'il est le président d une guerre
provoque une et une crise bancaire
comment l'économie grecque percer le
secret assez au malin il a la parole et
les gîtes au talent parce que tout le
monde adam qu'est ce qu'il va se passer
il ya des ménages toujours goût vous
aurez quitté l'europe il n'y a pas de
nécessité à ce moment là un sonnet paye
pas même c'est un bon parce qu ils n
attendent qu est ce qui va se passer
finalement et cette paralysie est
utilisé par les adversaires de la grèce
pour lui imposer de mes yeux
insupportable alors quand vous dites
adversaires de la grèce vous pensez à
l'allemagne et à la france peut être
aussi quand vous dites adversaire de
l'année serment quand même fort vous
pensez à qui malheureusement on
attendait beaucoup bliss l'appareil
france à vous êtes déçu que les pistes
absolument dissipation la dette beaucoup
de plus de la part de la france qui est
un allié traduit une somme à lier 30 a
dit que les allemands ils ont adopté une
autre position très bien et les et c'est
plutôt jeu politique
si parce que 6,6 il a réussi à changer
le type et les cocktails imposé aux
européennes à part belem alors toute
l'europe basé un petit psa ne levait pas
parce que pour le moment les allemands
gagnent de la crise au profil de la
grèce pour gagner d'argent
elle déploie pour l'aider quelques
organes oui mais vous dites qu'au final
tout le monde y perd à la fois la grèce
et l'europe en tout cas tout le monde
risque d'y perdre dans cette paralysie
de la zone euro si l'affrontement va
jusqu'au bout pour reprendre ma question
donc est-ce que vous pensez que le
compromis sera nécessaire que chacune
des deux parties devra faire des efforts
pour comprendre l'autre moi je pense que
les compromis est absolument nécessaire
et l'histoire de la communauté
européenne et de l'union européenne est
pleine de compromis la bonne volonté il
faut le faire nous sommes prêts à les
faire mais pas un compromis mais il
parle pas des retraites et humiliante
pour la grèce pas une retombée en
revanche ça veut dire que alexis strip
rats sera obligé de renoncer à certaines
parties à quelques mesures d'appareils
on a dit qu'on va par exemple on apprend
on a promis qu'on va on va avoir les
traits troisième
la treizième salaire
on a dit qu'on va le faire plus plus
tard par m'écouter hier le gouvernement
a annoncé qu'il va t'il voilà ces
programmes pour la crise humanitaire il
ya trois cent mille maisons anglaises
qui n'ont pas de l'électricien
trois cent mille personnes au cendre et
de l'hérault c'est insupportable
ça coûte pas mais on ne permet pas de
l'appliquer alors stelios coule dans ce
contexte de crise de crises humanitaires
que vous dites il ya des photos qui ont
circulé en france qui ont qui ont
suscité beaucoup de commentaires je vous
propose de les voir c'est le ministre de
l'économie yannis varoufakis qui pose
donc pour paris-match magazine français
aux côtés de sa compagne dans son
appartement d'athènes qu'on aperçoit
alors ces photos leur opulence ont donc
été très critiquée lui-même regrette
d'avoir fait cette séance est-ce qu'il a
cédé au glamour qu'est ce que ça vous
choque ces photos moi je ne ferais pas
ça mais de toute façon voulons pas qu'il
fait à ses côtés son bout son propre
boulot il fait un bon boulot parce qu'il
a il a annoncé le programme grec
ils insistent ils essayent de le faire
comprendre aux autres alliés européens
est ce que c'est un manque d'expérience
peut-être il avait laissé là il a dit
oui
il a aussi dit qu'il est qu'il n'a pas
aimé ces photos finalement ils arrêtent
et oui alors si il fallait faire
autrement mais c'est pas c'est pas salé
le comportement
individuelles de deux ministres n'est
pas le problème principal à ce moment là
nous avons des problèmes beaucoup plus
sérieux
justement de manière globale pour pour
terminer cette émission est ce que dans
quel état d'esprit sont les grecs et
vous-même dans quel état d'esprit vous
êtes face à votre pays vous êtes plutôt
optimiste ou globalement très inquiet
pour l'avenir
il ya un soutiennent sans précédent au
gouvernement il ya même des
manifestations en faveur du gouvernement
change qui qu'on n'a pas vu depuis deux
ans mais aussi l'extrême droite qui
progresse écoutez si si si lisa échouent
les prochaines le gouvernement n'est pas
mais ce n'est pas le gouvernement les
marionnettes des métiers ciblés qui vont
venir au pouvoir à thèze son l'extrême
les nazis parce que c'est un qui
profitent de la crise par la matière de
la crise de la moquerie si c'est qu'ils
ne croient pas aux élections qui ne
croient pas à la démocratie alors c'est
l'extrême droite qui va profiter alors
il faut que pour l'intérêt de toute
l'europe d'avoir un compromis profitable
pour tous les deux côtés
nous voulons faire des réformes mais
nous voulons faire de téléphone pas de
provoquer plus de chaos je vais vous
donner des exemples est désagréable
qu'il n'y a pas de réforme
effectivement je reste va pas sortir de
la zone euro ces deux fantaisistes
scénarios de sortie qu'on ressent à
chaque fois dès que ça va mal le grec
cite mais mais nous ne voulons pas
sortir de l'argent il n'y a pas un
précédent il n'y a pas de des normes et
des lois qui pisse force un pays dé
quitter la zone euro
nous voulons rester mais nous voulons
juste des généraux par avec des
solidarités est un outil paix de justice
sociale de justice sociale c'est un
message aussi aux allemands et la france
merci beaucoup stelios cole ou glaude
avoir été avec nous nous passons tout de
suite à la seconde partie de cette
émission l'europe c'est une force
économique c'est notamment la première
puissance laitière du monde et bien une
révolution va se produire dans quelques
jours
le 1er avril et ce n'est pas une blague
puisque ce sera la fin des quotas
laitiers les producteurs seront
désormais soumis aux aléas du marché
comment cette réforme est elle
accueillie par les concernés les
producteurs reportage en normandie dans
la manche c'est signé caroline motte et
gwenaël durand
yves sauvaget et éleveurs à saint-aubin
depuis 20 ans avec ses trois associés
il possède 70 vaches la traite c'est
noël jouenne qui s'en occupent tous les
matins à 7 grâce à ces appareils
il peut traire ses vaches en moins de
dix minutes
pendant ce temps là yves abreuvent les
petits vont me fais installer le 1er
avril 95 sous le régime des quotas
jusqu'à maintenant la production
laitière était régulée par les quotas
européens instaurés en 1984
l'objectif maîtriser les excédents et
donc garantir la stabilité des prix
le 31 mars prochain ces quotas seront
supprimés chaque éleveur pourra produire
autant qu'il veut yves sauvaget produits
480 mille litres de lait bio par an il
ne compte pas augmenter ce volume mais
il a anticipé
on s'est préparé depuis depuis plusieurs
années on s'est préparé à la fin des
quotas
nous on n'est pas les adeptes du volume
on préfère produire moins avec un coût
de production qui va être moindre et
avoir avoir une marge qui va être qui va
être qu'il va être le plus confortable
quand les prix sont bas eh ben on a
toujours des coûts de production qui
sont qui sont relativement réduit et
c'est ce qui nous permet c'est ce qui
nous permet de résister quoi en disant
40 % des exploitations laitières ont
disparu yves en est certain avec la fin
des quotas et la toute puissance des
industriels
cette réalité va empirer les industriels
ont le droit de vie ou de mort sur
certaines exploitations laitières
donc ça veut dire que demain à
l'industriel laitier va décider tout
seul si continuera à collecter monsieur
monsieur icloud monsieur y
les petits exploitants risque d'être
sacrifiée au prix de la compétitivité
aujourd'hui on est à peu près nous reste
à peu près 60 mille exploitations
laitières en france les perspectives à
l'horizon à l'horizon 2000 2025 dont en
dix ans sont de 30 mille exploitations
laitières tout au mieux c'est au bas mot
deux cent cinquante mille emplois qui
vont disparaître des éleveurs qui met la
clé sous la porte il y en aurait dix
mille chaque année à quelques centaines
de mètres d'ici eric launay a souffert
de la crise du lait de 2009
depuis cette date il a cessé de produire
du lait pour se consacrer à l'élevage de
jeunes bovins
une décision qu'il ne regrette pas pour
ceux qui vont rester ça va devenir de
plus en plus compliqué il faudra fournir
une somme de travail considérable faudra
être hyper pointu ça va être très
difficile quand on a beau se préparer à
une course dans l'athlétisme beaucoup
d'athlètes se prépare une beigne pas
forcément sauf que là en un an dans le
cadre de la fin des quotas laitiers dans
la course avec éliminatoires
si on gagne quand on perd on fait
faillite liquidation judiciaire aurait
songé à un redressement liquidation et
on disparaît du paysage à 70 kilomètres
de là à saint-aubin dupeyron
philippe robert est un éleveur inquiet à
56 ans il se prépare à léguer sa ferme à
sa fille mathilde on voit le double
maintenant que les quotas sont enterrés
par l'union européenne il compte
augmenter sa production de 10 à 20% mais
il sait qu'il sera soumis à des prix
volatils
c'est toujours nous lave à la variable
d'ajustement
on n'a pas de prix c'est très fluctuant
quoi on a on est à 90 euros de la tonne
d'or au moins par rapport à l'année
dernière
si ridicule ce aléas du marché nous on
nous demande
moi je demande c'est une garantie de
prix malgré ce contexte d'instabilité
mathilde de robert est décidé à
reprendre la ferme de son père après un
bts production animale elle devra
apprendre à gérer les comptes
à 22 ans elle est déjà bien lucide c'est
de la gestion aussi c'est l'histoire de
revenus faut savoir anticiper les coups
durs et pas trop trop profiter mes
vêtements fin de mon une bonne période
l'avenir est incertain pour tous les
éleveurs pour survivre certains refusent
de céder à la surproduction
quand d'autres parient sur la demande
des marchés émergents comme la chine ou
l'inde d'ici 2020 la production laitière
européenne devrait augmenter de près de
10%
on quitte la normandie retour à
bruxelles deux invités sont en piste sur
ce plateau de membre de la commission
agriculture et développement rural
j'accueille eric andrieu bonjour bonjour
député européen membre du groupe des
socialistes et démocrates et premier
vice président de cette commission est
en face de vous michel dantin députés
pour le ppe alors vous connaissez bien
tous les deux ce dossier les producteurs
qu'on a vu dans ce reportage semble
quand même globalement assez inquiet est
ce que pour vous ils ont des raisons
d'être inquiet est ce que cette
ouverture au marché
c'est une opportunité ou un danger eric
andrieu ben je crois que d'abord leur
potager et des biens me fais tout tout
est dit finalement on voit bien que ils
ont exprimé donc de façon très claire
que l'on est passé d'un outil de
régulation publique à l'outil de
régulation privée qui fait que également
demain la question de la régulation sera
portée par des contrats entre les
producteurs et les transformateurs
je crois que c'est assez juste que de
dire que ce sont les transformateurs qui
vont guider
tellement qu'ils vont être en devenir
les maîtres du jeu et que c'est pas
tellement à être l'informateur c'est les
industriels pour qu'on comprenne ce sont
les industries aulas qui achètent de
l'aidant et qui le transforme bien sûr
dont en produits laitiers sur du lait
soit des des fromages tout les produits
laitiers et la question ce n'est pas
tellement celle de du lait qui nous est
posée et ça a été bien dit dans nos
portefeuilles c'est celle que j'appelle
moi de l'économie territoriale c'est à
dire qu'effectivement avec les outils de
régulation de public
le lien entre la production et le
territoire était de fait mis en exergue
l s et es garanties à l'état s'il y
avait vraiment les producteurs a fait
une économie de proximité brin de
l'ensemble des territoires et je crois
que on peut parler de succès de réussite
de la politique des quotas depuis depuis
donc 84
là on est et ça a été dit mais on va y
revenir dans le débat on est vraiment
sûr de l'incertitude donc effectivement
il faut avancer là dessus alors michel
d'antan est ce que vous pensez que comme
on a entendu dans ce reportage que ce
sera la jungle désormais puisque c'est
le marché qui va qui va gouverner ce
secteur très important pour lampes des
quotas les dés du lait j'ai toujours
considéré qu'un producteur
cannabiculteurs rizzoli était un
agriculteur en danger en matière
laitiers il faut d'abord rappeler que 60
% du lait collecté par les coopératives
il y à quelques grands industriels qui
ont effectivement tendance à donner le
la au marché mais ce que nous avons
voulu dans le paquet mais c'est
effectivement une possibilité de
contractualisation dans le temps pas
simplement une contractualisation les
bonnes ou les mauvaises années nous
avons eu beaucoup de mal nous les
français à faire reconnaître cette idée
ici à bruxelles à faire notamment
reconnaître l'idée de la durée j'ai
gardé toute ma vie souvenir d'une
agricultrice collègue membre du groupe
libéral qui voulait que son mari avec
400 mille litres de quota puisse tous
les matins choisir son acheteur sur
internet
cette logique m'est étrangère je pense
qu'il faut effectivement asseoir les
choses asseoir les choses sur des
organisations de producteurs qu'ils
soient puissante et ensuite asseoir les
choses sur des contrats qui est une
durée suffisante qu'on comprenne bien
c'est à dire que dans le système tel
qu'il existera demain sans quotas donc
sans régulation de la part de l'europe
l'agriculteur qui a des chances de
survivre
ce sera celui qui s'est le mieux
s'organiser ou qui baisse ses prix ou
quelqu'un en pour faire simple ce sera
quoi qu'est ce qu'il faut pour résister
demain dans ce nouveau secteur dérégulé
je crois que c'est qu'il ya plusieurs
aspects dont il ya l'aspect à la fois de
grandir et de la position du lait elle
se rallier jeu réa la marge c'est à dire
ça a été dit dans le reportage entre le
le comment dire le prix du lait est le
coût de production on sur le prix du
lait est je reprends les propos de
michel dantin je crois qu'il faut
effectivement c'était l'idée du paquet
lait que les professionnels s'organisent
et de pousser l'organisation des
professionnels dont l'état est un
minimum de trésorerie puisqu'elles aussi
organiser ça veut dire se spécialiser se
structure qui se rassemblent avec eux
quand on négocie le prix du lait avec un
acheteur entre formateurs d'un
industriel de farcy on est humble
négocie pas grand chose et logiciels
plusieurs on va pouvoir négocier le prix
sacem premier aspect ensuite il ya la
question la question majeure qui est au
coeur du débat qui nous est posée c'est
raison de la volatilité des prix
puisqu'aujourd'hui il ya
il ya plusieurs types d'exploitation
égale les applications spécialisées qui
font que du lait est ce qu'on appelle
les votations dont en polyculture et de
gauche qui font du lait mais pas que du
lait et puis après il ya la spécificité
des productions de montagne qui est
encore une autre aspect alors vous
connaissez bien les régions de montagne
répète est laid je me suis battu pour
faire adopter un amendement qui permet
aux produits sous signe de qualité de
maintenir un système de gestion de
l'offre
alors je regrette que l'administration
française est un peu compliquée
complexifier le la gestion du dossier
ce que nous avons voulu faire c'était
une gestion simple il faudra t'y revenir
mais chaque région chaque producteur
doit quand même faire attention à son
marché
moi je suis parfois consterné de voir
dans certaines régions des producteurs
qui n'ont pas de conscience de ce à quoi
sert leur produit il faut que nous ayons
une démarche globale et je voudrais
revenir sur un chiffre je vous ai dit
tout à l'heure que 60 % du lait est
collecté par les coopératives
malheureusement 60 % de la marge de 2,2
de la marge louis est fait par les
industriels à se remarier plus innovants
qui ont été plus innovants pour fournir
au marché des produits à forte valeur
ajoutée qu'ils attendent vous vous en
désolé alors c'est un c'est très
technique comme question va essayer de
la simplifier je vous propose notamment
pour cela d'écouter le président de la
fédération des producteurs de lait il a
des inquiétudes une question concrète à
vous poser écoutez
aujourd'hui nous savons qu'il peut y
avoir des terrains difficiles et moi
j'interpelle les pouvoirs publics
français et européens
justement sur quelle politique demain
après les quotas le marché est l'unique
le marché ce n'est pas une politique
c'est un constat donc une politique
européenne
c'est justement pour essayer de gérer
les périodes de crise et l'ins période
de crise comment l'europe vient aider
les producteurs
parce qu'on sait très bien que dans une
période de crise c'est toujours le
producteur qui au final payé sur le prix
du lait alors la question centrale au
coeur des préoccupations qu'est ce que
l'europe a prévu eric andrieu pour
remplacer les quotas rien ou une polynie
notre politique pour l'instant à ma
connaissance rien s'il ya bien sûr et le
paquet lait on en a parlé
vous allez vous entendez des sénégalais
ont bien vu trois éléments majeurs qui
ont été mis à disposition dans le paquet
c'était le premier élément c'était
comment dire ça a été dit l'organisation
des producteurs c'est de la négociation
sur ce contrat on se rend compte qu'à
l'échelle des 28 états membres la
musique des contrats entre les
producteurs et les transformateurs n'est
pas n'est pas homogène sur l'ensemble
des des états et ensuite donc ça a été
la possibilité en zone de montagne de
réguler finalement la production si on
voudrait on prend bien vous êtes quand
même inquiet de situation de
surproduction qui peut se reproduire
demain qui pourrait réaliser mais je
suis inquiet parce que la politique du
lait pose la question plus largement
même du modèle agricole ars
effectivement on peut dans la mesure où
on coupe le lien entre la production et
le territoire on peut être des acteurs
qui accompagne la désertification d'un
certain nombre de territoires et si on
concentre la production parce qu'en fait
il cela marche et qui va commander donc
ça a été dit c'est effectivement d'être
amateur qui vont avoir la main la
question des contrats entre les
producteurs et les transformateurs est
elle suffisante je ne le crois pas je
pense qu'il faut aller au delà il faut
que les contrats s'articule autour de du
producteur du
under mais également de tous les réseaux
de distribution sont des pistes à
creuser
il y à la question de l'observatoire du
lait quitte à qui on doit donner une
vocation plus forte en matière
d'anticipation des situations de crise
et de se donner des outils de gestion de
crise plus performants tels que nous
avions proposé au parlement européen ici
au parlement
michel danthe à la question qui va se
poser demain dans un univers très
concurrentiel ce sera aussi la question
des débouchés
est ce que l'europe sera assurée demain
d'écouler sa production de lait vers
d'autres pays notamment vers la chine
faut d'abord constater que la population
mondiale croît de 50 millions de
consommateurs par an donc oui le marché
mondial avec la solvabilisation d'un
grand nombre de pays est en croissance
mais il faut d'abord que nous donnions
les moyens de faire face à la volatilité
dans chacun des pays comment ça c'est
moyen d'une part le cm renforce les
capacités de l'interprofession à gérer
un marché il faut qu'elle prenne les
choses à bras le corps
et puis il faudra aussi qu'il faut aussi
qu'au plan national la fiscalité évolue
il faut que l'agriculture
l'agriculteur pardon puisse thésauriser
les bonnes années sans être surtaxés et
puissent réinvestir cet argent placé
dans l'exploitation et mauvaises années
alors pour faire très simple la
confédération paysanne réclame à
bruxelles un outil concret pour gérer
les stocks de lait c'est ce que ce que
dit michel d'antan où il en faut
d'autres
oui moi je suis convaincu que la
suppression des quotas laitiers a été
l'hymne équilibre économique et
qu'aujourd'hui le marché le seul marché
ne réglera pas tout loin s'en faut
donc ça veut dire que vous regrettez un
peu cette politique qui a quand même
bien marché qui a été l'un des points
forts depuis lors il a t'il personnel de
masse et un peu la certitude
oui bien sûr dicle dans l'incertitude et
l'incertitude en matière d'organisation
de la production et du lien dans la
production et le territoire
effectivement aujourd'hui on le voit
bien il ya vraiment la question il y
aura besoin d'outils de régulation
puis on a bien compris donc les gestions
de crise vous êtes allez vous reprendre
l'europe c'est pas une nébuleuse
alors hop c'est les décisions de 28
ministres de l'agriculture 60 le mot de
la fin avril
2 751 parlementaires européens il n'y
avait pas de majorité ni au niveau du
conseil ni au niveau du parlement pour
maintenir les quotas nous devons prendre
acte les français on était plutôt
quelles que soient nos sensibilités
politiques
on était plutôt des pros quotas il faut
aujourd'hui en prendre acte et que nos
politiques nationales et européennes
s'adapte à ce nouveau contexte donc le
chantier va être les devants nous encore
encore très bien ce sera le mot de la
fin merci à tous les deux d'avoir
participé à ce débat c'est la fin de
cette émission rendez vous la semaine
prochaine avec nora ahmadi même lieu
même heure ciao